[Music]
[Applause]
well give the fat man beyond I'm Kevin
Smith hey I'm mark barnard hey we are
back being here at this scum and
villainy Cantina right here on Hollywood
Boulevard in Hollywood California where
they make the entertainments put your
hands together so the folks at home know
your real ladies Joe how are you mr.
mark barnard what you been up to I am
I'm good man I'm good
oh my god you sound like the highway no
I've been I've been working I've been
going to the movies and seeing some [ __ ]
I've been Memorial Daniel izing if
that's a adjective adverb a candy coin
it was excellent I went to go see
Aladdin did you see did you see Aladdin
it could be great anything's possible
III saw Aladdin back in 92 so I'm good
no offense to that company I know they
didn't do very well by taking our
childhood and remaking it and [ __ ] like
that and I'm sure sooner or later I will
intersect with one of those live-action
remakes but you know and I'm not like
dissing guy Richie or [ __ ] Will Smith
who's lovely and I've worked with him a
lifetime ago and stuff for a minute on
Jersey girl I just you know I was like I
is it do they sing never had a friend
like me
uh-huh I seen that but it is amazing and
like sometimes I still sing it it's real
fun and [ __ ] I just don't even know if I
need somebody covering it for me yeah I
don't know and I'm not even like I'm all
for him doing it I just I wasn't going
there you went and I did go it was not a
whole new world it it was like I used to
work in the newspaper business
good headline not a whole new world no
it's fine
is it good time like for a fort for a
kind of Craven crash crab it's fine it
is not as pointless to me as beating the
beast was okay it gives me the beast was
just like why why would you do this at
all and then it makes a billion dollars
and then that's all you'll never going
to see is new versions of these things
that you loved when you were 8 why so
then why was one okay and the other was
not this had the opportunity to actually
do a little bit of course correction I
think from the first one in that they
cast brown people to live in a place
that is filled with brown people even if
it's a fictional place even if it's
Agrabah at least it's you know we found
Middle Eastern sort of North African
actors to play characters who would be
as such but which is kind of cool they
added a new song for Jasmine who never
really had her own so I'll get out of
here in the first one what is her song
her song is is speechless and that it's
kind of her what song is it I will not
be speechless I will not sit down and
take the the sort of the assaults of
patriarchy and tradition blithely I will
not be speechless when you tell me I
can't be the Sultan I won't let me
speechless when you tell me I got to
marry this Prince and I don't want to
marry this Prince I want to be my own
girl like it's it's that song so it's
kind of like the it was the song the
Belle sings I [ __ ] like
[Laughter]
remember the exact words to the song but
I'm sure useful on the subject I'm gonna
read [ __ ] and then it sounds like it's
compat mixed with the Little Mermaid a
part of your right yeah yeah like that
the problems with the movie come when
you compare it to the original yeah
which is often because it is that so
it's inevitable I mean how do you do
that how do you make a Latin and go like
no it's the genie and he's blue just
like the one in the cartoon without
making somebody go like oh yeah the
cartoon which is like I just don't get
why they made them blue like why why
does the genie need to be blue either
because if they're our childhood I guess
but if like you you got me already
there's a genie
dude rubs a lamp genie [ __ ] comes out
that Jones Will Smith so [ __ ] hot
yeah rub it rub it make no make a wish
Aladdin it'll come true yeah man I beg
let me direct that it would have been a
lot of [ __ ] close-ups on the lamp
rubbing and [ __ ] and the genie would
have shot out like a [ __ ] art being
arcing rope up jism just Aladdin be like
this how it look good as Guy Ritchie oh
she's a great-looking guy Ritchie who
also seems to kind of not understand
that the Middle East is not actually
India because the end of this movie has
like Bollywood dance numbers I'm like
you just can't like swap out brown
people and make them dance and be like
no it's fine
sorry guy Richie this is not how that
works
we're gonna go to such lengths to cast
you know appropriately which they did
they [ __ ] like went to the hills to
find actual like people of that region
to do this job I mean like that kind of
from India I don't know maybe Bollywood
people love it the if I remember
correctly Guy Ritchie's a white guy yeah
he loves it he loves it to death but I
kept I came out of there just wondering
like why this isn't the Jasmine movie
right like why it couldn't be the story
of a young like a sequel quasi sequel or
[ __ ] like remake it but from her
perspective do the Maleficent so just
call it Disney's jazz so down with that
you know like what if there's the girl
who wants to be the Sultan but can't and
what's the girl who wants a phone love
but can't and then that girl finds a
[ __ ] lamp like what happens if she
gets a genie what does she wish for and
Aladdin can still be the dopey love
interest look let me show you the world
like I don't need you to show me the
world I got a [ __ ] lamp and a carpet
I could do that [ __ ] myself son you just
look cute steal me dates it is a rather
suggestive song now that I think about
it I can show you my world but what
you're talking about is that would never
[ __ ] work at Disney because it's an
original idea yeah and they don't shots
right I mean in the in the world of what
they're doing they're taking like weed
I'm glad Aladdin worked out for him
because ten minutes ago remember Dumbo
came out and did a malformed and stuff
so they keep remaking the cartoons which
I get it's printing money I predicted it
wrong years ago man when like Pixar
became a thing I remember having this
conversation with Scott Mosier where I
was like I guarantee you this company is
one day just could go into their library
and just Pixar everything so they're
gonna take Dumbo the original [ __ ]
soundtrack and [ __ ] and just make it a
forty version or whatever [ __ ] CG
version and that would make a lot of
sense I had no idea that they're like oh
you think we're just going to remake
cartoons as cartoons hold my beer and
then [ __ ] went and opened up the
vault and they were like bringing in
life with real people that's just kind
of crazy to me I think that you were not
wrong I think you were just skipping a
step because I do totally believe that
in 12 years we get the CG version of the
live-action version of the cartoon of a
Latin no [ __ ] let's see man I don't know
how to play the long time Disney does
they're like oh you [ __ ] idiot we
have to make money for the next four
billion years yeah it's just a perpetual
motion machine we're just gonna keep
remaking it oh that's fine they can do
whatever they want over to the main hub
man as long as they leave Marvel the
[ __ ] alone because they're making
original movies and I'm happy with those
movies very happy i sat down today at
veggie grill to have lunch and I watched
Captain Marvel again and I never cry at
veggie grill because I love it so much
but [ __ ] that Stan opening [ __ ]
credit secrets the Marvel credit
sequence has nothing let's stand it and
then says Thank You Stan just [ __ ]
got me again and there I am eating my
beyond burger weeping and [ __ ] like that
just a total commercial for the
carnivores who were like sea food so bad
these vegans cry but the food was good I
was just I was emotionally swept up in
it man [ __ ] that movie holds up and then
somebody pointed out remember last week
we were talking about
there ain't no Marvel movies after
spider-man there are two dates they just
haven't announced what they are yeah
there's a couple in 2020 there's a
there's a May and there's a November
wait go back to 11 because I gotta know
yeah is it still the same ending that I
had in the cartoon yeah and it still
works like it's still spoilers that are
now fifty years old
Aladin saves his last wish the genie
cannot have to be a genie any more like
he frees the genie and then there's the
moment because again like Will Smith is
not the worst actor in the world he can
deliver that moment where he like I
didn't think anybody would ever do this
for me and it's emotional and it's a
little like yeah [ __ ] I'm not a monster
I can well up at this because that story
is so bulletproof that it kind of works
right but it's the road to tell him that
sorry the pit stops you take that I
would have welcomed a little diversion
from the story that I thought that I
knew and I that diversion would have
been I mean it would have been like just
shift the perspective the tiger eats the
monkey the tiger goes Tiger he needs
everybody
well don't be ridiculous but do you like
animals eating animals that's [ __ ]
metal well yeah I would have thought
that a company that is so much about the
princesses might have thought like hey
what if this is about the princess
hey the bird spoke in the movie yes
speak in this movie yeah do you really
yeah was it Gilbert Godfrey because I'm
about to buy a ticket if it was there
like we changed everything except the
bird
oh we know the bird was the best part
here is Gilbert got me I don't know
dialogue gives you stuff like he's not
bitching out you far and they're not
have [ __ ] that movie then man because
god damn it the bird was the best part
of that movie [ __ ] I hate when they do
[ __ ] like that with a like we're doing
the realistic version of Aladdin the
bird can't speak and it's like meanwhile
here's the genie come on man in for a
penny in for a pound man if you're gonna
do it do it and [ __ ] did a monkey was a
poo right yeah
did he [ __ ] I know he didn't speak in
the cartoon but he was like wow oh and
[ __ ] like that did he do that
does the money die
that look on your face was just like oh
I will have one of the heart to tell him
the monkeys only in the first half he
[ __ ] eats it in the Cave of Wonders
the [ __ ] tiger ate the puck
how is the game a wonder sequence
Kevin wonders is it's super cool but
it's because they wanted to make it real
it is somehow less vibrant fancy that
then the cartoon which is kind of
glorious and lovely in the lava feels
like it's real and it's or as real as
that was going to be in a [ __ ]
cartoon 1992 guys we did CG lava it's
just it doesn't none of it quite has
that pop and that's that was the sort of
sad part is that it felt like a cover of
a song that you really really liked by a
band that's ok and trying their best
have you seen many of these oh this
[ __ ] really low-key shade man that
took me a minute to catch up to it so
low-key and stealth have you seen many
of their live-action you said you saw
Beauty and the Beast I saw be gonna be
karela did not Corolla which they're
totally making a karela movie are they
yeah I think I think I'm Emma Stone is
playing young crows Vil Thompson is
playing old gorilla
there's an Emma involved I mean honestly
if they were like Emma Stone and Emma
Thompson Emma Watson I might [ __ ]
they might have my money I'd be like I
got to see the two Emma's
yeah man you like Jungle Book I did
lectin was it faithful they do all the
songs there's not a ton of songs and
gentle book I know there's like the
parent necessities like well and I want
to be like you right
so yeah they did those two and that did
they do trusted me with the snake who
was the snake wasn't like did she sing
it yeah she sang trusted man she can
sing she's got like albums tell you guys
are making me interested to see this
jungle book remake for the first time
like first when I saw the trailers I was
like
it looks like the cartoon I saw that
moving on I I and for his Craven as I
thought this was and it's Craven I said
the beating the beast was I will still
show up for Lion King [ __ ] tomorrow so
see there it is everybody's like why do
they keep doing this cuz you're like I'm
going because like a missed algae's a
hell of a drug and if you scratch that
right nostalgia like [ __ ] am I gonna go
and not see James Earl Jones do Mufasa
for the last time [ __ ] stuff he would
be doing would it be the last time did
he uh well I mean you don't know there
could be a lion king - don't [ __ ] say
that
oh my god man cuz that just is not just
his dad that's [ __ ] Vader's well I I
am convinced that somewhere like they've
had James Earl Jones like do the Mission
Impossible thing where read this
sentence this sentence contains every
phoneme in the English language so we
can now digitize your voice for the good
of all mankind they could do a deep fake
up absolutely it would just be easier to
have somebody be like I sound like James
Earl Jones never quite do though I don't
know man [ __ ] the guy who does Kermit
sounds like Kermit get that guy to do
jars Vader I am your father
I went to the movies just [ __ ]
moments before I came here
yeah me and the kid and her band went to
see and it was supposed to be just me
and the kid but then her BAM wanted to
go and then I wasn't gonna be like oh
you guys go cuz I actually did want to
see the movie and [ __ ] but then I was
like the odd wheel out because the old
band was there and I'm like hi I'm the
groupie you're the manager I'm Reuben
Kincaid and sure we went to see
book-smart [ __ ] it was good yeah
really funny really well done [ __ ]
funny movie and [ __ ] but we'll can I
tell you what I thought was hands-down
the best joke and that there are many
great jokes in it but Will Forte is in
it for like a minute plays one of the
girls dads and he's married to Lisa
Kudrow two very [ __ ] funny people but
the bit is
that like they're the parents of the one
girl and the girls want to go out to
this party and the parents were putting
together a pre graduation because they
graduate the next day so it's a pre grad
night feast and all the dishes were like
named after graduation and [ __ ] so we'll
Forte's going oh no you can't go man we
what about we put together the mash the
mushroom cap and gowns and [ __ ] like
that
and they're like we got to go but then
the one he said that [ __ ] made me
laugh he goes oh you're just gonna leave
and you're not gonna eat the kind of got
to get it right hold on you're not gonna
eat the salami being your dad has been
the greatest honor he's a genius man ho
ho he's [ __ ] wonderful the two girls
in the leaves of fantastic across the
boards man really [ __ ] well cast
really well made movie enjoyable as [ __ ]
also this was the week and I know I'm
[ __ ] late did you ever watch Cobra
Kai I watched the first season and watch
the second season oh my god dude I like
first I watched the first two free
episodes and I was like this is good
then I got busy living life and [ __ ] and
then I saw the billboard for for what I
thought was again I was like why are
they putting up another and then I saw
the Chi have it - it knows like oh she
had there on season two so I went back
and rewatched this first two episodes
and then I was like you know what I am
gonna pony up for YouTube I did the guy
you press the button yet another [ __ ]
app you know [ __ ] just because you want
to see one show and [ __ ] but whatever it
was [ __ ] worth it bro of all the apps
that I've [ __ ] bought over the last I
don't know [ __ ] five years buying
that YouTube app just so I could watch
that show was a [ __ ] religious
experience I had so much [ __ ] joy by
myself because my wife refused to watch
it with me
like a real [ __ ] I I was just like are
you out of your [ __ ] mind like this
is a sequel The Karate Kid she was like
it doesn't mean as much to me as it did
to you I was a quat how could the story
of a young man from New Jersey who
becomes a karate champion in the valley
not appeal to you so I went on the
journey by myself and my god
did they do a great job this look it
can't it's it doesn't do it justice to
say this is what I would have done if
they gave me that [ __ ] show to do
number one I would never be that
creative
I wouldn't even thought to [ __ ] do
what they did
number two even if they were like no no
here's the plot line we don't trust you
either so just [ __ ] do this
I still wouldn't have been as creative
as they did that show is so [ __ ]
enjoyable man from start to finish cast
really well continues on the story in
this incredible way I paid to see that
[ __ ] in the theater when I was when I
was younger like I I'm right and then I
went back to Japan with him as [ __ ] and
I was like and then I want to I think I
went as far as kk3 cuz I remember Crees
came back and then was the next one the
next Karate Kid I was Hillary Swank yeah
that was when I was like what Daniel saw
is not in it I thought the Karate Kid
and I flipped a table and stormed out
and [ __ ] but now I hope to god they
bring [ __ ] Hilary Swank into the
[ __ ] series because it's just become
this like awesome melange of like the
great like they pull it like they
created the universe there was a
universe there because there were a
couple movies and [ __ ] but they honor
the universe and go deep in it Daniel
and Daniel is like a cart you seen it I
have seen it he's a modular she's got
Daniel as a car dealership in the valley
Larusso autos and [ __ ] where like you
you know they'll kick the [ __ ]
competitors and shop prices and if you
buy a car you get a bones re-entry so
it's it's all like [ __ ] seated in
from but that's like the easy
easy [ __ ] they managed to make a family
melodrama
out of it and get like 10 episodes of
season they're like true half hours not
even like TV 22 minute half hours packed
man so that's like five hours at five
hours total so 10 hours for two seasons
that felt to me like and this some
people may not consider this compliment
but as [ __ ] perfect as the Degrassi
universe that's what it felt from you
that's high precise [ __ ] praise they
did high school insanely well dude and
that's what you forget is like that's
what Karate Kid is a high school story
yeah but like it's in the summer mostly
but then the school year begins but you
never really think about because it's
all about him doing that crane kick this
year and and this whole [ __ ] series
is like high school kids and they do it
insanely well I saw somebody online said
yeah but it's cheesy I'm like [ __ ] you
it's like the best cheese on the planet
like they like cheese done well is who
don't like [ __ ] cheese I'm a vegan
and I'm saying that [ __ ] who don't like
[ __ ] cheese and if it's done really
well and this cheese is done insanely
well oh my god I it was a rapturous
watch the whole [ __ ] way they took
Billy
I mean was Zabka zapped cos character
Johnny yep and made him the hero but not
but not the hero like the antihero like
and he's like kind of like fallen on
hard times he's also like a [ __ ]
personality and stuff but it's kind of
like Scrooge like you know how he's not
visited by three ghosts of the night but
it's lolis Turner's [ __ ] around and it's
like you know I'm sure some people be
like come on bro it's a very simple
formula where the kids are gonna make
him better and he's gonna make the kids
better I didn't see that coming man so
like and I'm a writer and I must be a
bad one because that was coming like at
me like a train and by the end of the
series I was like oh my god they helped
each other be better and [ __ ] like that
but his performance is [ __ ] wonderful
but I love the fact that he's like it's
not like by the end of season 1 he's
like I'm a changed man he's still kind
of an [ __ ] to some degree it sounds
like you like it
because it's like the bad
bears of karate yes which the movie
wasn't no no the show directed by John
Jay Adelson who directed hockey yes and
rocky like the bad news bears and
spoilers on a damp down note Bears don't
win rocky don't win
Crowley kid though he won but there was
a minute I don't if you ever saw it
where it looked like he wasn't gonna win
but then [ __ ] sweep the leg Johnny oh
[ __ ] well but that's the appointment
at that like if you look I remember
seeing that movie in a theater and I was
like a [ __ ] kid watching that and
when he was like sweep the leg and
Johnny looks at him with surprise and
he's like you know [ __ ] do it and
[ __ ] and then he sweeps the leg and then
he's but he wasn't like that he was more
scared of his sensei and [ __ ] no but
that's that I was that was crazy I was a
pretty good crease right there so he
goes back in and he [ __ ] does it
stole but he instantly [ __ ]
apologizes right he's like I'm sorry man
I'm sorry I'm sorry
so like there was some good there and
then at the end when [ __ ] Daniels you
know [ __ ] kicked crane kicks him and
[ __ ] he gives Daniel the truth trophy
and he goes you're all right Larusso you
deserve it you won but there was a
little bit of [ __ ] like a tiny bit of
redemption there which I never really
[ __ ] thought about they built an
entire [ __ ] series on that little
moment of like maybe he's not such an
[ __ ] like maybe he is a good guy who
just got some bad information in life
and it turns into the story of like kids
that had a bad sense II who just like
gave him bad info and it's affected all
their lives in season to him to spoil a
little bit for you in season 2 there's
an episode episode 6 dude one of the
finest pieces a half-hour I've ever seen
in my [ __ ] life in it Johnny is
hanging out with his friends from high
school and they are the same dudes that
rode [ __ ] bikes and you know kick
body back in the day those guys weren't
busy don't be a dick
[Laughter]
one of them the one who's like can't get
him a body bag remember that dude in the
tournament his character has [ __ ]
cancer and he's in the hospital and he's
[ __ ] wasting away so they they take
him out on one last ride and they get
him [ __ ] bike and like they cut
between the old footage of them on
[ __ ] motorbikes and now they're old
men on those like fat bikes the
middle-aged men ride and [ __ ] like that
no offense if you're one of those people
but you know wide bike something like
that not three wheels but like they got
like saddlebags on the side I'm really
over explaining because I don't wanna
get my ass kicked by motorcycle
enthusiasts and [ __ ]
in any event they're riding they go up
to the [ __ ] lake and hang out and
they reminisce they get in a bar fight
and [ __ ] they have like a great [ __ ]
day and this dudes like on his way out
and [ __ ] and he's got a conversational
moment with Johnny bout a fire like
where he's talking about Ali who was
Elizabeth Shue in the movie and now here
they get her back not yet hold on hold
that but all right they might get her
back bro yes it's [ __ ] crazy and if
they do it'll be a stunning [ __ ]
achievement and I will get there ask me
again so yeah he's like going I wish I
had asked her out but you asked her out
first and [ __ ] like that and then he's
gonna you know you had it all [ __ ] easy
go you got one thing you know that I
don't know you got one very important
thing right now you got time he's like I
don't have that [ __ ]
so he winds up passing away spoilers on
the bike at night no by the [ __ ] fire
effect but that would have been amazing
[ __ ] Cobra Kai never dies
and then dies yeah it's real Thelma and
Louise moment he just dies in the night
and [ __ ] and then they're trying to like
revive them and you realize all the guy
did [ __ ] die and the end of the
episode they zip him up in a [ __ ]
body bag
it's [ __ ] poetic Wow and nobody ever
says they don't even echo the line like
they just know that you know your [ __ ]
and by the time they get to that zip I
was literally like I mean telling you
man some people call that cheesy rhyming
that is [ __ ] fantastic if you can
make me some people be like you cried
everything but if you can make me
[ __ ] cry at 5:00 in the morning
well you're high as a kite yes you have
done something that everything else has
done including like breakfast no it's
[ __ ] so well done man
Ralph Macchio is good great and he came
back all the Miyagi talk like tears at
your heartstrings like Miyagi really
[ __ ] meant something to Daniel so
much so that he carried him all the way
into adulthood meant touching [ __ ] like
that
the last episode of season 2 is a
school-wide [ __ ] karate brawl that at
one point there's a hallway fight that
is almost as [ __ ] good as the
daredevil one in Netflix and not because
you're like look at this [ __ ] like
brilliance it's just they managed to
choreograph a pretty good [ __ ]
hallway fight where as one fight dies
and other starts and [ __ ] like that
it's pretty [ __ ] dazzling and then
they get there's a mean [ __ ] twist at
the end of the season where you're like
nah how which you only feel that because
you're so deeply invested in the
characters I love the old-school
characters but also [ __ ] love the new
characters they've [ __ ] created Miguel
and whatever the other kids yeah I know
all the names I know they look like man
I'm on
that's the one button Miguel I knew his
name and [ __ ] because at the end of the
season I was like wow like real loud I'm
sure it is a thing of beauty man it's an
absolute thing I wonder the people who
are doing it I wish I knew all their
names there's like four names whenever I
look at the credits and legs a lot of
people but you know what it's a great
[ __ ] argument for all-hands-on-deck
have made it a great show like you know
what I'm saying it's not one person
going this is my vision it's a bunch of
people who really feel like we have been
given something important to hold on to
me in crowd a kid like one of the best
films ever made in the history of cinema
not like the finest but like you can't
not like that movie except maybe my wife
what [ __ ] her like [ __ ] like that
movie is so just rousing as [ __ ] it's
for every outsider it's for anybody
who's ever dreamed of accomplishing
something like that it's it's like I I
dig it I dig it more than Rocky
like and not it's not a competition but
that one speaks to me more than the
other one and [ __ ] so did you know that
people and the people that are doing it
they feel the same obviously the same
way I feel about it and so they have
Shepard this thing so particularly so
you feel the fan love you know it's just
like it's absolute fanservice
up there with with an end game in terms
of like we know what you like about this
and we're not gonna overdo it but we're
gonna it's always going to be there
we're gonna sprinkle it over everything
we're gonna make things work
thematically they had one episode that
was entitled the glory of love which was
the song from Karate Kid 2 and he got in
a car with his wife because he was avid
Daniel's having problems with his wife
and [ __ ] and he put on the music and I'm
like oh my god they're playing Gloria
love but it wasn't glory of love it was
just another song by Chicago Peter
Cetera sound-alike ins yeah but for a
minute I was like oh my god they got
Gloria Love and then I was like this
ain't [ __ ] glory love because I was
trying to sing along and I was like
I am a man who and their words didn't
match at all oh my god I had such a
[ __ ] good time watching I cannot
[ __ ] recommend it enough it's you
don't necessarily have to know the
Karate Kid movies like to know it they
remind you about the rivalry left and
right and stuff but it helps but it's
it's so well done you could go in dry
which sounds [ __ ] dirtier than I
meant to but you didn't it's oh I love
it it's my favorite thing of the week I
was like ah more of this and [ __ ] less
of everything else in life now I want
these guys to do sequel series for
everything remember I have an idea for
like you do a sequel series for the Bad
News Bears we're stuck at Kelly leak and
Amanda and they've got a coach new kids
team and [ __ ] and you could totally do
that like that anything honestly this
[ __ ] series has convinced me they
need to sequel eyes everything as a
series before we die everything we ever
loved if they came at me and they were
like we're doing a Happy Days series I'd
be like take my money [ __ ] and I
didn't even know I want that but like a
sequel series and [ __ ] oh it's [ __ ]
great they should do it with like Star
Wars well I guess they do it with Star
Wars all the time do you know what is
equally good and a hundred percent less
fun what Chernobyl I watched episode one
yeah it definitely is missing the
lightness of [ __ ] Cobra Kai I mean
it's riveting and I've never felt as bad
about the hope for Humanity as I feel
watching Chernobyl which is just hey not
great people making awful decisions that
are gonna sentence hundreds of thousands
of people to either immediate death or
vast awful genetic and dis for Matiz
that will last forever
[ __ ] spoilers dude yeah sorry
meltdown in sin they well-acted yeah I
mean there's there's a little bit of
weirdness in that every single person
who's playing a Russian is a Brit and so
like my wife said that she's like why
are all the Russians British like this
buddy take place in Star Wars land yeah
like especially given that there's only
three people who you actually recognize
like stellan skarsgård Jared Harris and
and and [ __ ] what's her name Emily
Watson are the only actual names and
everybody else you've never seen before
everybody else have a Russian accent I'm
just saying I feel you but it is it is
incredibly well made TV about a subject
that is incredibly hard to watch that's
treated incredibly well how many
episodes there's only there's four now I
think it might be just going to five
five or six five all in exact does it
have a happy ending I mean no other than
they stopped massive catastrophe and
settle for just mostly catastrophe mmm
here see the pictures of what those that
area looks like now like yeah the
abandoned areas you should there's a
whole series on the Science Channel that
my wife loves to fall asleep to called
mysteries of the abandoned yeah and they
spend an hour every week just like
here's a thing that used to be a thing
but it isn't a thing anymore
because nature took it back or here's
the bridge we were building in the
jungle and decided to stop building it
so now there's just it like 700 feet of
elevated roadway in the middle of the
[ __ ] Yucatan like yeah this is cool
here's a tunnel they were digging in the
Santa Monica Mountains to help evacuate
Los Angeles when they thought it was
gonna be like a nuclear target that just
stops because they realized they could
never evacuate Los Angeles to a tunnel
in the mountains like that's a bad idea
what year did they think they could this
was like 44 45 I think that's like
American can-do is him right there like
we're gonna tunnel in the mountain and
save us all we carefully put the
mountain like this is dumb like we're
gonna be traveling single file through
this they snuck I don't work oh my god
that sounds like something I Stephen
King's The Stand but yeah so it's a
whole show just about [ __ ] that used to
be something that now
like here's an airport they built in
France that was never really used but
it's still around because nobody figured
out what to do with it and there's now
just an abandoned Airport which is eerie
and weird and [ __ ] like terminals and
everything that they just gave up on
like a [ __ ] de Gaulle is gonna be our
Airport has nature come in um some of
the recent [ __ ] not really some of the
older stuff yeah and it's cool it's cool
thing well of life I'm sure yeah there
was this one in China that used to be is
on Islands China has like a thousand
islands in its you know vast East China
Sea
that's not what it's called let's just
leave me that and it was it was a mining
town and so they built this village on
this island and then they vacated the
mine and just left this village and in
50 years
it is now looks like a village made of
leaves because nature's completely
reclaimed it and they forgot that it
existed until some like young female
photographer was like that looks cool
and took a bunch of pictures and it's so
[ __ ] eerie just to see an entire
architecture reclaimed by Nature
it's like I am Legend but like less bad
so funny you want you went there I was
like sounds like when you go to your
school after school's been closed for a
week and [ __ ] and it's all empty and
it's like this is weird but I like your
version better because your version
involves a zombies all right is that all
we've got to catch people up on oh one
last thing did you see the trailer for a
terminator dark fate I did yes how do we
feel about the trailer for chairman Tim
Miller did Deadpool and I'll watch him
do anything cuz that [ __ ] Deadpool is
an amazing movie and so I'm sure is
gonna be movie worth at least watching
Arnold's back Linda Hamilton's back is
it which and it's this is the one that's
a direct sequel to Terminator 2 yes so
they're ignoring everything that's
happened a hundred percent that kind of
thing is to be supported
sequel as everything and then forget we
made that they should really make a
melodramatic highschool show as a sequel
on YouTube why would you think of the
trailer I thought it's cool but the the
tenacity for people to make like fetch
like they're gonna try and make a
Terminator movie work even if we haven't
given a [ __ ] about the last four
Terminator movies like just this this
desire to make fetch work this desire to
make again like no we listen how many
old things can we bring back that you
loved once like we got on the wagon now
the king of the old things you loved
once James Cameron yeah cuz that's the
big sell this time totally they're gone
like he's back over the first time is he
directing no he's busy with the blue cat
movies but he's [ __ ] he's he's back to
read the script and say yes he's like
you got to imagine it's gonna have like
you know it's good edge to it because
that's the Terminator
baby daddy right there theoretically
well hey man what's his name I mean she
watching has been back before though
like this is not the first time he's
returned to the franchise yeah I mean
when did he leave
what was the one that he wasn't in bless
you
well the salvation the equation had the
fake a young the seroma yeah so he was
kind of a he's never not been in one of
these and we kind of stopped giving a
[ __ ] after I guess rise of the machines
might have been the last one we kind of
cared about right a little bit I mean
it's fine right it's like oh look it's
terminator yeah look I hope people are
supporting seeing old men playing one
role they've ever played their whole
life
because this fall I got one of those
coming out
[Applause]
I'm going Disney original with this one
man all right we got news we got some
news Oh mark barnard and he went
trolling on the internet and found us
some [ __ ] news to talk about ladies
and gentlemen give it up for Mark Bedard
he's got the news I feel like any like a
theme song for the news I know right
like just some kind of just like snappy
not even like a lot of salt a lot of
lyrics just a little like duh and the
news I think you just did it [ __ ] it
cut and print it sounded amazing I'm
with you you got that JC I'm gonna put
that in every episode hey so you
remember when the guys who did Game of
Thrones were like we're making Star Wars
movies yes what are you missing pen
Sharpie black one anybody got black
sharpie meanwhile go on with your story
and we were like yeah well it was just a
black sharpie I asked for I don't get
pissed off [ __ ] here's one Foxx like am
I gonna have to cut up this black
sharpie my father was killed by a black
sharpie anyway back to you sir so yeah
we all had kind of assumed that the next
Star Wars movies would either be Benioff
and Weiss the Game of Thrones guys we're
gonna go off into a trilogy or ryan
johnson who was also handed a trilogy
post last Jedi but the news that we got
is that they are making a oft rumored
and hoped for trilogy that we didn't
know they were making which is Knights
of the Old Republic oh sure yeah yeah
Wow so they're going old school they're
going old school they're going four
thousand years before [ __ ] obi-wan
Kenobi and Anakin Skywalker's it is yeah
yeah they're going deep so far the only
name that's been surfaced is and I'm
gonna absolutely butcher her name but
it's late akela green
Lita Keller greta's Zack again my man
with the pronunciation who Sheeran
altered carbon the first season she had
written a terminator movie if I remember
correctly but yeah she's she's sort of
like a highfalutin TV and film writer
who also worked with James Cameron on
the Avatar the 19 sequels of that that
he's making was she the one credited on
the first one as well yes she came up
with the idea right and we're vice-versa
there's a connection there I remember
she was involved in the first one or
something right so wait she's doing the
next star well she is writing the
Knights of the Old Republic the first
didn't what is that ledge idli going to
be a trilogy what do you know what that
story is uh other than didn't like Ben
Kenobi refer to it once yeah I mean I
played the first videogame it's based on
a video game series but that was years
ago and like a platformer that I don't
have anymore so I'm gonna read what they
said in the press about what it is
because that's my job is to read [ __ ]
that I found on the internet in the
Knights of the Old Republic game the
player helps fight an uprising against
the Republic led by the villainous Darth
Malak a Sith Lord the player eventually
joins forces with but he's best still
ashamed a Jedi Knight and one of the
most revered female characters in the
Star Wars extended universe the story
has everything rookies droids the Jedi
Academy the force giant slugs chips dips
chains whips little candle wax on the
nipples ooh
[Applause]
but none of the characters we know and
love no what about a young Yoda I mean I
don't think he's 4,000 years old I think
he's well 800 900 years old I mean
unless they're kind of retcon how old
Yoda is so then who who's the who's is
there any yeah there's darth's but no
Darth that we care about now it is all a
whole brand-new series of characters
because I think part of their their
impetus is to break from the Skywalker
that whole storyline and just let's go
old let's go way back let's look I'll
give it a shot but I mean it's gonna be
lightsabers oh I'm in and Jedi's are
they yeah that might be maybe that's how
let's do some speculating okay if
they're like hey we're gonna give you
the three New Jedi movies maybe that
means that they are wrapping up the
Jedi's in the last Star Wars movie
because they got to go backwards to do
Jedi story mm-hmm that's a good call and
we are going to get a Star Wars movie
every other December until the end of
time I thought they were taking a couple
years off let me check I actually wrote
this down because last week we were like
no Marvel movies coming and it turns out
that there were so I did some more
research checking I know on the Internet
fire away um let's see 2022 is our first
next Star Wars movie so they're taking
three years off two years well no the
very next doors of 2019 three years off
then they're gonna corral us over to the
Disney Plus thing so that we watch the
Star Wars stuff there mm-hmm
and then they'll make us miss it for a
while and hype it on the Disney Plus
thing and then they'll Brinks two hours
back to trumpet fanfare man for the
first time since the saga ended a new
saga yes now it could be mentioned the
Republic it could be the Benioff movie
that many often wife's movie it could be
the Rian Johnson movie we don't know
with that first Star Wars movie will be
but at least we have a little intel on a
thing Lucasfilm is working on that is
seeming to make people happy is again
lightsabers yes which is a universal
good more Star Wars always good thing of
a Sith Lord and then it's a bad thing
yeah a big terrible all right I'm on I'm
on board you're on board yeah they can
have my money do you remember when
Warner Brothers said that they were
gonna remake Akira live-action yes
they've been threatening to do that for
years they really have it's it's had a
bunch of different aura nations like the
huge brothers we're going to make it at
some point
Leonardo DiCaprio's company was going to
produce it if they still are but the
director they found is super interesting
takeaway tt you know uh-oh give that guy
all the movies Micah and so that they
actually announced a release date the
next to a release date things so that's
out may 21st 2021 they're actually
making it so there are two years away
yeah okay look if anybody's gonna make
me care about that story it's gonna be
that guy cuz I saw the you know the
brilliant animation and I still don't
know what happened in that movie it's
like the last 10 minutes of trading
places where I'm like wait what happened
I guess it all worked out
I know somebody won but I don't know how
or why is a beautiful movie that I
thought was I just never quite
understood it so hopefully he'll make it
easy palatable for somebody of my low
intelligence to be able to comprehend
what was going on do you know what
happens in the story of Acura I mean I I
know that it's about cañedo whose best
friend Tetsuo gets kind of captured by
the military government science wing and
they do [ __ ] weird experiments to him
and he turns out to have like mental
powers but eventually it becomes like
crazy body hard because it's like left
arm rebelled against him and destroys a
stadium in Neo Tokyo maybe and there's
like a giant teddy bear that's some so
you don't know [ __ ] about Acura
apparently oh my god do you remember a
lot about that [ __ ] I forgot about the
arm
I wrote I rather doubt about all of it
matter of fact I was you could be making
it up for all I know I mean I rode with
it pretty hard until again like that
last act when it's what is happening
here baffling
hey I gotta kill my buddy who's got a
crazy veiny dildo arm and like I got a
laser cannon and I keep shooting the
dildo arm but it doesn't die so when the
dildo is growing so it's weird and and
yeah he dies at the end me
gotta be a metaphor yes I was like yep
that's what happens um all right he's
doing it anybody in it not yet but uh
but Leonardo DiCaprio was still
producing it got the cool bikes it's got
it's got [ __ ] awesome bikes um and
look you'd that dude [ __ ] thor
ragnarok is a brilliant movie so uh I'll
give it a shot
are they allowed to make jokes in it cuz
that [ __ ] Acura was a very sad tune
god I hope so
like you don't get taken unless you're
like no we got to be a little funny yeah
a lot when we little cartoons are you
watching and I'm behind like five
episodes but are you watching what we do
in the shadows my kid is and she's and
she's doing that constantly she's like
you must watch this as a guy well I will
I never thought Staten Island would be
as funny as it is and what we do in the
shadows because that's where the vampire
lair is in Staten Island
yeah which the minute they told me was
that my only [ __ ] that's perfect
nothing good happens in Staten Island
I'm sorry
firemen and cops and retired cops
retired farming all of whom live in
Staten Island
clearly I shouldn't drive through Staten
Island anymore yeah I'm not co-signing
this that's Diane Island's a fine place
yes sister to New Jersey you guys he's
back yeah
last bit of news before we we bring on
our shiny ass guests yeah I know no it's
a shiny no fine we're gonna have
somebody worthwhile to speak to this
this time the last little bit is at the
third season of Jessica Jones as its
release date when is that it is June
14th I just came from the ArcLight where
I went to see book-smart and they were
having some sort of Jessica Jones
premiere there mmm that a big step and
repeat and a bunch of people that's cool
bands and stuffs I guess they're doing
the premiere there tonight showing an
episode or something all right when do
we the rest of us get to see it June 14
the era this is the end of the Netflix
Marvel Universe no more as we know no
Punisher part two or anything or do they
they did part two
I think they were like with many of
these things like three or four scripts
into season three same thing with
occasional the plug so this is it
I mean Feige has in the press said that
it's not like I have decided never to
show you these characters again they
just have no plans for these iterations
of the characters so there's a world in
which you know Krysten Ritter could come
back as Jessica Jones and my Coulter
could come back as Luke Cage but they do
not yet have a plan for that to happen
and they're now they're switching gears
to TV that's more like many movies yeah
so Falcon and Loki and Scarlet vision
yeah so yes Alvin let's pour one out for
the [ __ ] good old Netflix Marvel
heroes man who kept us kept us you know
patient and kept babysat us as we waited
for the next Marvel movie and always
hoped that they would reference them and
[ __ ] and boy they really [ __ ] went
out of their way not [ __ ] along it's
just like somebody just like this
everybody was like who else you want I
was in the theater like daredevil bring
it back but apparently he wasn't needed
in the end game but it's yeah I mean
what amazing shows they were we talked
about before that daredevil hallway
fight one of the greatest pieces of
television ever produced man at [ __ ]
fight scene is fantastic and boy did
they do daredevil right not like you
know Affleck didn't or something but he
didn't have as much time right he had
one movie these cats went deep Charlie
Cox was astounding [ __ ] it was great
across I didn't say anything over here
like I was about to go hard on
what was your favorite of the Netflix
Marvel Netflix laugh I think the first
season of Jessica Jones yeah yeah I
think I think for me it's it's the one
that was about something yeah in a way
that the others weren't quite and the
metaphor was so strong and the problem
and is such a great villain that uh that
it elevated it for me in a big bad way
and I loved the first season at
daredevil it's amazing and I and I liked
the first season like the first half of
the first season of Luke Cage I think
when they did the villain switch it kind
of loses its path a little bit but if I
like I like that whole first season yeah
I think I like them in order of how they
came out with the exception of Iron Fist
nowhere near the list yeah yeah yeah we
could have done without that
yeah the world would have been a better
place nobody needed that no it was
challenge maybe needed like a build up a
way to kick a guy when he's down way to
iron fist him right up his ass and then
open up in a wave alright so that's it
that'll be it for the Marvel Netflix
stuff indeed
well they got Mark Miller now right they
could do a whole bunch of Miller worlds
they have nothing but Mark Miller and
Mark Miller worlds I got a bunch of [ __ ]
I mean it's Netflix they're throwing
money and everybody except us to make
sure don't say it like that but yes
you're absolutely right you know who
else they're throwing money who our next
[ __ ] guest well what a perfect
[ __ ] segue is that in for the news
and that is it for the new mark found
the news give it up for mark we're done
with it now generally at this section of
the show we dive into Q&A but oh we got
special guest for you today ladies and
gentlemen
bonafide [ __ ] screenwriter man who I
once had the honor of working with on my
very finest hour on flash an episode
called runaway dinosaur he wrote the
script for that he also wrote the script
for the first Thor movie he also wrote
the script for x-men first
he also wrote the [ __ ] script my
writers class first class my bad first
contact it's a better movie nobody ever
saw about the x-men like the board meet
the x-men vs. yes that was the crossover
well done
first class and he--and way to catch it
and then tonight though he's here to
talk about something that he created ro
he did he created out of whole cloth it
is his first solo screenplay credit
because many of those are the things he
did with his old writing partner ash
Miller but rim of the world which
premiered on Netflix last week and blew
up on Netflix but Zach may or may not
tell us how many millions of people
watched it and more millions of people
than watch anything else that weekend
period wow man that's [ __ ] dope yeah
that's got to be cool I wonder what it's
like to have a Netflix show we'll never
know but let's find out from somebody
who does man give it up for the man
who's bringing you the rim of the world
ladies gentlemen Zach stats and yes I
against the wall and yes I've I've heard
all the jokes already so you know just
go ahead which jokes about the title
come on like cause it's like Pacific Rim
but in other things oh my god put that
together man I can't believe I went
there and you didn't get kids in the
best half can say that's why I didn't go
right for rim job in my head I was like
children involved and I will I will
thank you for everything for that
how did this happen man like we were
just out in the alleyway talking before
the show and I was like this is based on
a kids book or something and you were
like no this is mine and yeah no it's
it's look man I'm about the same age as
you guys I grew up on the grape kids
movies of the 1980s and the great kid
and teen adventure movies of the 1980s
they used to make a few of those a year
you know The Goonies et explorers I'm so
glad you stand by me the Monster Squad
so many
so many others like that I loved those
movies growing up those movies were very
important to me growing up and it felt
like they kind of stopped making them
like a lot of other categories of movies
that we love the studio's kind of
decided that people weren't going to
roll out for them and back in early 2016
I had an idea when I was actually I
guess it was mid 2016 because I was
dropping my kids off at summer camp up
in the San Bernardino Mountains on rim
of the world highway and I was driving
down and there it's you're like 6000
feet above sea level and you can see
like all of Southern California spread
out before you and I just had this kind
of vision like wow what if this was a
war zone and like the kids from the camp
had to go into it and that was like kind
of a little kernel that it came that it
all grew from and I was like kids summer
camp alien invasion boom and lights
itself
it writes itself except a few critics I
think maybe said it did all of that
being said I sat down and write wrote it
I had a relationship with McGee and this
really cool lady Mary viola who runs his
company we'd worked on something else
that didn't happen and I was and he was
having a lot of success with the
babysitter this kind of cool later than
that for a movie on Netflix and and I
was like well that was a five million
dollar movie I have something that's
more like maybe 25 30 million spoiler
alert it turned out to be twenty million
when all was said and done and Mary read
the script and really liked it McGee
read the script and really liked it it
took a year to make the deals because
Hollywood sucks but then because Netflix
is Netflix after the deals were made two
and a half months later were like
shooting the movie and then a you know
10 months after that it's dropping on
Netflix on Memorial Day weekend and
gazillion people around the world are
apparently seeing it teenagers are
making memes are they already making you
know their memes so I figured that
that's like the surest sign that of
success before we'll jump back in to the
president but take us back in the past
when did you get started writing you
just want you in the life when did you
get started writing when writing Chris
or writing all your whole career um you
know I started in the early 90s I like
mark I was a journalist before before I
was a screenwriter but I always wanted
to be a screenwriter when I was in when
I was a journalist I freelanced for
Entertainment Weekly I never made it to
staff writer like cool guy here listen
I'm just better at that I know right the
one thing I'm better than you are I got
my first job and TV like in 2000 on like
the the the most low budget syndicated
action our back when those were things
Gene Roddenberry's Andromeda it was the
one with the Kevin Sorbo the mullet
himself before he turned into a complete
lunatic and yeah exactly
me too but you know it was like the
greatest job in the world my ex-partner
and I we did agent Cody Banks we're like
yeah we own this town and then we didn't
work and then we did another line from
the movie and we didn't work the banks
Bank that was me trying to be like you
know Vincent entourage or something but
and then we didn't work for three years
and then we worked on the Terminator TV
show which was indeed terminator in high
school the Sarah Connor Chronicles
really that show was a there was a
there's Summer Glau from Firefly playing
a terminator in high school
it wasn't small wonder it was actually a
lot better
that's no wonder and then we you know we
ended up doing this show called fringe
we ended up doing Thor in x-men that was
another like you know like yeah we had
to hit movies in 28 days it's gonna be
like this from now on and then like none
of our movies got made we got paid you
know that like you get paid no I don't
know that tell me tell me how to make
that happen for myself I mean like when
you were doing like Superman you know
when you were doing like Superman
scripts and things like that like that
like studios were paying you money but
no one was actually making anything and
you're like I just want people to see my
stuff what does that experience like
what is it what is it like writing for
years on [ __ ] nobody gets to see it's
sucks man except for the Czechs those
those those don't suck but ultimately
like I didn't get into this you know
there are easier ways to make money than
doing this job you know I I did this
because I've got like stories in my head
that I want to share with people and
that was you know eventually don't want
to get into it the writing partnership
broke up and I was kind of rebuilding my
career and I was working on this Booster
Gold thing for for Greg Berlanti and
Greg was like I got a new baby I'm not
gonna be able to engage for a couple
weeks but hey when a ready flash episode
and I was like yeah I love the flash I
had only seen one episode but I watched
a bunch of episodes and they're like
Kevin Smith is directing and I was like
oh yeah
oh just the guy who made me think that
it you know idiot from a small town you
know in in the middle of nowhere might
actually be able to do this for a living
now you [ __ ] see me yeah myself cut
too I wrote a little script called the
runaway dinosaur
Kevin directed it and it showed up it
was my after I've been writing
professionally for like 16 years at that
point that was my first solo credit
and it kind of remains one of the two or
three things I am proudest of in terms
of like the freakin pure emotional
content of like Barry coming to terms
with the death of his mother and
learning how to forgive himself and that
was because of this dude right here on
the page so that was all on the page
did you see recently this season of
Supergirl Erik Carrasco who wrote on
that show he included an homage to
runaway Dinah to her so I heard that
that's so awesome there's the Russian
super girl the daughter read daughter
and they're trying like Lex Luthor's
dude there I don't think it's even Lex
the the Ukrainian kaznian wherever she
is the Russian people who find are
trying to teach her English so they'll
give her a children's book and it's the
exact [ __ ] book that we used in flash
but it was just with Russian titles and
stuff they should pay us for that [ __ ]
man that's that's how you know that
we're sinner it's like oh that was so
nice that they did that Oh Marge it's
like do they owe us money no okay I
guess it's okay I wanted when we did
that episode I asked him like you guys
should put this [ __ ] runaway dinosaur
book out in stores like we're at least
on the DC website like people would
[ __ ] buy it exactly originally it
originally started and it was you know
because I've got kids you've got a kid
yes interesting tell him what it was it
was the runaway bunny which is which is
a story a classic children's story and
it's about a mother's love for her child
and how however far you go I will I will
bring you back and they're like okay
well you can't have the runaway bunny
can you do something else and I was like
what else do kids like dinosaurs and so
it became the runaway dinosaur and and
it ended up being sweet and like very
cool it was it was a zero hour change to
they thought
I had run away bunny up until like the
day before we shot and they were like
just in case we should have a another
concept ready to go and then it became
runaway dying
how much of that book did you write any
of it it's oh yeah like they read it out
loud they read big chunks of it out loud
and this we have all of it somewhere uh
no you know you write what you need to
but I mean if you put a gun to my head I
you should write a [ __ ] kids book
Zach I will I will
the dude I'm working for Travis Beacham
right now who did Pacific Rim but it's a
show called Cannavaro and it was the
first script the first feature script he
ever wrote 15 years ago was on the very
first blacklist and he's been living
with this story for now like 15 or 20
years and if you ask him like hey so
what are the days of the week called
they're not Monday Tuesday Wednesday
Thursday Friday he's got he knows all of
the [ __ ] beige of the week in
whatever [ __ ] language it is if
there's a poem somebody's reading he's
got 50 pages of that poem written
somewhere like if you had runaway
dinosaur like you have you finished it
and you got like pernil to do the art
for it like you could sell that book I
mean maybe I should yeah I don't work
like Travis I'm more like you know the
stories from when they made aliens of
like how great those sets were but if
you like turn the camera like this way
it was just plywood like that's kind of
my brain it's like it's like if it's on
screen it's there but you turn it that
way just plywood yeah he take us through
the Netflix world because that's
something that we don't know anything
about and then look let's be honest they
dominate our industry so let's hear from
somebody who's been on the inside it is
they are a juggernaut I mean they've got
like this seemingly endless stream of
Wall Street money and what they don't
have is a lot of IP and the fact that
they don't and I'm sorry IP intellectual
property they don't have a lot of things
that they already own like the way that
Disney has both their own back catalog
and the Marvel and the Star Wars that
translates into an opportunity for
people like us because they're looking
for new they're looking for new things
so you can walk in through the door and
in my case I
walked in through the door with a
director who they had a relationship
with McGee and with something that was
new but that kind of reminded them of
other things it's like how about a
Goonies meets Independence Day want to
do that and they're like yes we do they
were like super super difficult about
the money but like creatively they're
like kind of go make your movie I hear
they're more hands on and on the TV side
but they were super supportive of of
what we did and the thing about working
with Netflix is you know like I'm saying
this is someone who like in June of 2011
could walk around LA and like every
frickin theater and every freaking
billboard was like x-men first class
Thor x-men first class Thor like that's
kind of nice for your ego like there is
nothing like seeing that frickin movie
30 feet high but if you go to Netflix
it's gonna go it's a different
experience it's pushing a button it's
pushing a tile on your screen but what
that translates into is potentially a
lot more people watching your movie we
you you were talking about book smart
like book smart as this great freakin
movie that if it came out in 2009 would
probably be this runaway hit but like is
only gonna end up doing like eight or
ten million dollars for the weekend if
if book smart had debuted on Netflix
this weekend like 15 million people
around the world would have watched it
and it would be the only thing everyone
was talking about on social media right
now it's it's a huge new world that that
it's now an option that you can go and
pay 12 bucks to see Aladdin or you can
go down you know you can sit home call
up your Netflix screen and say I want to
watch kids fight aliens and and it's a
you know in some ways a comparable
experience though I think we spent like
a tenth of what they did yeah
you have to sell anybody on the idea of
like Netflix works too it's like in many
ways that's what I've always hoped for
my whole career or like [ __ ] the
theatrical step like it's so difficult
you spend in the case of clerks - we
spend five million dollars making a
movie and then we spent ten million
dollars advertising the five million
dollar movie the metrics just don't make
[ __ ] sense in some cases in the case
of you know Avengers endgame you've
spent 200 million to make it if you
spend a hundred million to market it
worldwide that just makes sense because
you're gonna pull in whatever they're
about to pull in over you know more
money than eight trillion dollars
exactly they're gonna create new [ __ ]
names work but like I've always been
about how many people can see I just
want as many people as possible to
[ __ ] see it and that's what Netflix
offers that's fine I never understood
when I first got in the business like
there was this real big chasm between
movies and TV and people like oh that's
TV and I'm like [ __ ] TV is a more
powerful medium than film it reaches far
more [ __ ] people on a regular daily
basis but TV people like the movies like
I remember Jay Leno once was talking
about I was I used to do that show quite
a bit and do bits on the show and he'd
always come back and chitchat like
before the show began he's a nice dude
but he would talk about like the movies
we made his god man it was [ __ ]
movies and not even night heat that he
specifically loved any movie I made but
just that I made movies and I was like
what are you talking about you do
[ __ ] a show four or five nights a
week man like [ __ ] like I make a
movie once every two years or something
he goes you have a movies man they last
forever he's going we make a show and
then at the end of the night nobody
[ __ ] sees that show over again they
don't talk about it [ __ ] happen we
move on we just what we do is disposable
it goes what you guys do everyone takes
their [ __ ] time man and it means so
much more I was like you believe in the
[ __ ] hype man TV like reaching the
widest possible audience that's what
every storyteller wants so go on a
Netflix like over maybe slugging it out
at the [ __ ] box office like cuz
there's no guarantees like yeah going
into this weekend everyone's like books
no Mart's gonna make a bunch of money
and then it does a pretty [ __ ]
respectable number but people like oh
it's a [ __ ] disappointment it's like
you [ __ ] nuts that anybody left their
houses to go see a movie don't have
somebody with a [ __ ] cape or a
[ __ ] giant glove with gems in it yeah
like that's that's to be [ __ ]
applauded in [ __ ] I mean what once upon
a time there there was the you know
obviously there was a huge difference in
terms of quality but now like you've got
amazing visuals and in TV as well and
visual storytelling you know when I
first started writing in the early 2000s
the advice was pretend you're writing
for radio because you know no one will
pay attention to the visuals anyway now
it's a lot different than that and the
last I feel like the last distinction
between the two was okay well the one
thing the TV can't compete with movies
on is spectacle you know you're not
gonna you're never gonna see an TV show
you know a freaking dragon lay waste to
a whole you know convoy of dudes and
thousands of people on horses and you
know guess what that distinction has
been erased is that distinction is
watched as well
what are you talking about I think a lot
of it is also psychological right I
think some of it is is again that the
time that you have in a movie to perfect
that movie you know whether it's whether
you get it over that perfection line or
not but you can iterate and you can work
on and you can you can devote actual
man-hours to and in the evenings early
as like the early mid-2000s you couldn't
give that kind of teat time to a TV show
he's good everything was 22-episode
everything needed to be happening as
fast as possible to get it done to get
it on and move on and nothing could be
given the time to make it right
nothing be could be given the time to
make it great or the money that would
come with oh [ __ ] you're getting
actually just there's a giant ice wall
and there's a big [ __ ] blue drug and
it's gonna blow through a blue smoke and
it's gonna look awesome you could never
have done that before because nobody
could have made that argument but no we
can spend two years making 10 episodes
of TV and one million dollars and it
makes sense and it's gonna make sense
until we're like and then bran won the
[ __ ] throne man
that's right it credits an inside source
told me how much the last I heard from a
fairly reliable source how much the last
season of Game of Thrones cost it was a
lot more than reported it was something
like at least what I heard was two
hundred and forty million dollars versus
episode four six episodes which is like
sin 2:24 is what yeah it's like thirty
million dollars in episode yeah it's
like oh my god that's so much but that's
less than Justice League which which
piece of entertainment did more for
Warner Brothers coffers in the last two
years
Justice League or the last season of
Game of Thrones
boom Game of Thrones better investment I
don't think any but still pen per
Starbucks and I also feel like Netflix
has done that thing where cinemas have
forgone the mid budget anything like
they either want miniature they want an
indie that's like glorious and shiny and
and you know Lady Bird or they want
infinity war yeah they want endgame and
that idea of you could make a movie that
cost between twenty and forty million
dollars and an audience would show up
for it and it's a kind of movie they're
not getting anymore it's a romantic
comedy it's the kids adventure movie
it's it's that it's that nostalgic for
the thing you don't get anymore let like
they they skated to where the puck isn't
yet and they found the oh [ __ ] there's
still an audience for this I think the
first few years of Netflix making movies
they kind of threw a lot of stuff at the
wall to see what would stick and what
and this is my theory is what they are
increasingly figuring out is what sticks
is exactly what Mark is talking about
it's the midlist it's the movies that
people have demonstrated that they love
people people didn't fall out of love
with rom-coms they just fell out of love
for paying twelve bucks to go to a
theater and see a rom-com like you put
to all the boys I loved before
or on a Netflix in a zillion people
watch it a billion and a half people
don't quote me on that
are going to watch that Ali Wong rom-com
when it drops this Friday what is it
always be my maybe because it looks
freaky and entertaining it's got all
these laugh lines it looks heartwarming
it looks wonderful and it ain't gonna be
in theaters it's gonna be on Netflix so
if if any of you are screenwriters or
aspiring screenwriters I think though
you know like it's an exciting time
right now because these kind of dead
categories of movies are coming back to
life as long as you're okay with them
going to streaming instead of instead of
going to the big screen first smart
strategically to I think if you're a
screenwriter and you're like oh yeah
Netflix Zak went in with the exact thing
that they're going to need even more
coming up once all their Disney [ __ ]
goes away that leaves a Disney size hole
in Netflix is programming so anything
that they had from the Disney library
that isn't you know [ __ ] Marvel and
[ __ ] like that any of those kids shows
and [ __ ] they now won't have at a
certain point and that's what they're
going to need because that's a parents
use Netflix to babysit their kids so if
you got kids shows ideas like this
genius right here you probably got a leg
up going in there right now and not just
Disney remember all of the streaming or
pretty much all of the studios are in
some stage of starting their own
streaming services warner is about to
launch there's DC Universe will probably
fold into it somehow
yeah Universal is going to have a
streaming service paramount is gonna
have a streaming service and what does
that mean that means they're going to
take all of their libraries and all of
their content from Netflix from Amazon
Prime to put on their own services what
does that mean Netflix and Amazon Prime
and the other independent streamers they
need to put something on there that
means they're more original content
which means yeah more jobs for people
like us hopefully
if you can say and this might be a thing
that you can't talk about what is what
is the favorite what is your favorite
movie that you wrote that won't ever
come out oh man that that I know won't
ever come out no will never come out my
ex-partner and I did when we were
working at Fox and working on x-men
first class we did a secret movie for
them that essentially I can't tell you
what the plot was but I can tell you
that it used all of the characters that
all of the Marvel characters that Fox
had at the time in 2011 it used the
x-men it used the Fantastic Four
it used daredevil it used Deadpool
because again they were you know
daredevil was still it was still at Fox
at the time and it was a really cool
freakin script and we almost had Paul
Greengrass directing it which would have
been really cool but he had another
project to do instead it didn't end up
going but it would have been ascribed I
was really proud of and it would have
been really good so what this was at Fox
this was at Fox in like 2011 really
exist anymore so which doesn't really
exist anymore so maybe they won't sue me
for it for it's for for revealing even
though I didn't reveal what it was
called and then the other the other
thing that's never going to happen is
the version that Ash and I did of the
Fantastic Four which was the alt which
it's funny josh trank who ended up doing
the Fantastic Four that we saw in the
theaters we were supposed to be writing
the script for him but no one told him
that we were doing it and so when he
officially signed on he was like why are
you imposing these other writers on me I
want to use my own writer I want to do
my own script and he did his version
instead and it was it was one of the
things it was one of those hammer blows
to our career at the time even though we
had gotten paid because I was so
freaking proud of that script it was it
like how I like they were young and it
was like it was how the Fantastic Four
were almost the fantastic five except
for someone a young man named Victor Von
Doom who was just too damaged and [ __ ]
up to be part of them and it was a again
script I was very proud of Josh Trank
didn't want to do it
I in one of the moments that I regret
most in my career I expressed a little
bit of schadenfreude at how that version
of the Fantastic Four ended up crashing
and burning and you know what I don't
feel good about that
you shouldn't even though it freaking
hurt like a [ __ ] that they that
he didn't use our script I don't blame
him like if you were a director and
someone said like use a script like
wouldn't you like automatically like
like kind of put your hackles I wish
that somebody had said on yoga hosers
here use this script no I mean honestly
in that situation if I'm picked by the
studio I would have at least read your
script and been like oh [ __ ] this is
dope maybe we can add to it or something
like that you know a lot of the work had
already been done you know Victor Von
Doom is a hacker yet hey let's see that
movie so long story short I regretted
expressing schadenfreude it or something
you know like not on like like on my
Facebook page which I had forgotten was
being read by you know all of the Fox
executives who who did that movie that
was really good for my career and
friendships but you know I apologized to
everyone and the really nice thing is
like a couple months ago when they were
announcing like Josh Trank's like Al
Capone movie and I was like hey it's
like it's really great when people come
back from failure and
come back strong and reinvent themselves
artistically and I said like you know he
threw out our script and like and I'm
still not rooting against him and Josh
Trank reached out and was like hey man
that was really nice of you to say and
we kind of like in private
like kind of buried the hatchet and said
yeah that was a really hard time none of
us covered ourselves in glory and isn't
it great that we can all root for each
other success and and go on and do new
things now so that was like a that was
like a really nice kind of little
redemptive thing that is but what I get
out of that is like Josh Trank is doing
an Al Capone movie that's what that book
I the Tom Hardy movies and yeah that's
him that's Josh Trank he wrote that
script for my eye but I didn't even know
that it was about Al Capone Tom Hardy's
playing Al Capone Tom Hardy's playing Al
Capone yeah I think you might have just
[ __ ] broke that news I've not seen
right now you know it's it's it's it's
been announced you also a hacker not a
hack
Tom Hardy is gonna play our Capone in
that movie yang like mess it's I don't
know all of it but it sounds like he's
gonna be playing like a syphilis ridden
Al Capone one at the end of his life in
Alcatraz like thinking back on his life
but his brain is but because his brain
is rotting away from syphilis it's all
like nonlinear that sounds [ __ ]
amazing
doesn't that sound oh yeah and that'll
be a fantastic comeback for the
Fantastic Four yeah absolutely
it's out right needless to say so
long-winded way of answering marks
question like yes I have you know like
like being a being a working
screenwriter this is a horrible
tasteless comparison but it's kind of
like being a parent in the 18th century
you know like you have like eight you
have like eight kids but like maybe if
you're lucky three of them will grow up
as for the rest of them don't get too
attached
[Applause]
but as consumption is a thing so post
rim of the world you know you're sitting
on top of the proverbial world just
[ __ ] it to death what what uh what is
what is tomorrow look like for you is it
is it more as much as possible original
stuff or are you kind of still doing
that thing where there's an open writing
assignment this is that can say hey we
got a new take bows are the clown you
want to come in a [ __ ] oh my god I am
working on
I developed an animated show for Netflix
that's gonna drop in 2020 that I can't
announce the title of but it's like
based on a big property so I did that
thing I'm doing an original script with
Greg Berlanti and Warner Brothers that
we're gonna try and sell in June and who
knows if that's gonna happen or not I'm
writing a couple of original things and
I am chasing I'm getting so close but
god I'm probably gonna curse it by
saying I'm getting so close a project
that I would really love that's like a
adaptation of an anime that's like one
of my favorite animes that Keira it is
not a carrot it you know what happens in
a Keira can you explain what the [ __ ]
have no idea guy yells Pineda a lot okay
good I'm sure but but yeah there's like
there I even though I swore like I'm
just gonna like I love doing originals
I'm gonna do originals and then they're
like hey this one's an open writing
assignment and like really okay I'm
gonna go after that and it's really good
directors too it's it's the people who
did it
it's Andy and Barbara machete who are
like super freaking talented so I am I
am
hopefully I'm having the last meeting
where I will either get it or I won't so
it's but it's it's now down to it so
there were a bunch of people up for it
and you're vying for there's always a
bunch of people up for it I'm not you
know people are like oh you must be at
the point in your career where you can
just say yes or no to
I'm like no it's like it never stops
being a cattle call man or maybe it does
for you know like Steve Zaillian but I
ain't Steve Zaillian well [ __ ] I ain't
even Zacks dance man [ __ ] you're
doing fantastic bro like legit fantastic
I just I just hope that we can work on
something again together all right no I
mean you know it's funny like when when
I first got the script and got the gig I
you know I liked the script very much
but then they told me like oh they
worked on he worked on Thor with his
partner and he worked on x-men and stuff
so I knew like you had bona fides and
[ __ ] but like at that point it was like
oh I'm like I'm directing his script
that's like good for him
now I'm like oh I got to direct Zach's
script good for me you're on a [ __ ]
roll man I'm like [ __ ] well done and
[ __ ] let's have you come back here with
us and then we'll do some Q&A man come
join us behind the bar its way I'm gonna
go behind the bar can I like get another
whiskey sour
we are gonna dive into the Q&A portion
of the show ladies gentlemen this is
that the time where we turn to you the
audience and ask you what you want to
talk about and they want to ask us we've
nearly we say that like the questions
have to be relevant to just me and Mark
but now we've got a third person here so
maybe include Zack and Matt as well let
me move this bottle keeps falling Zack
I'm gonna jump out and you jumped
between us
okay slip back there
I got a bunch of booze in my dick now
what did you get to drink so convert I
got a whiskey sour you want it no [ __ ]
no man that's [ __ ] that's a writer's
drinking clearly I'm not one of those
Mike all right there's JC the proprietor
of this here place he's the guy who gave
us a safe fun cool [ __ ] spacey
environment to come hang out I give it
up for JC JC we'll pick the three people
man three people gonna be asking
questions tonight and if their question
is super [ __ ] great
they're gonna walk away with some prizes
number one they're gonna walk away with
a couple tickets to 40x theater thanks
to our good friend Brett deacon and the
folks at 40x
if you've never seen a movie in 40x what
the [ __ ] is your problem then if you've
seen the movie in 40x you haven't won
tickets at this [ __ ] show man so my
Wynnum go if you don't win them try it
out man next action movie it's
definitely something I haven't on a
relatively good authority that Godzilla
will be the next 40 X Joe that would be
[ __ ] wonderful I guess you have
kidney stones then go see [ __ ]
Godzilla and I don't have kid because
those [ __ ] right out so you're
gonna get two tickets to go see a 40 X
screening and you're also gonna get one
of these amazing fat man beyond Prince
by the great naval guns Allah's way
three people are gonna walk away a
signed by me and Mark and Nate and if
you wanna if you want one and you
haven't won one fine young Nate and
they'll sell you one before you leave
here tonight all right here we go man
what's your name young camper my name is
Lauren what is it Lauren oh well Aria
like yeah like Lauren Michaels but
switch the and the Ilia
everybody give it up for like Lauren
Lester's hello give it up the Lord man
thank you
what up all right before my question I
just need to say two things one mark
last time I was here was black man
beyond I had longer hair and you said I
looked like Ed Sheeran that ego boost
has just kept me riding throughout the
year man if I got you laid you did not
but you did sign the genius comic book
so I don't know how that compares but
Kevin I have to say thank you to you
because you gave me one of my first jobs
in the industry because I was a PA on
cop-out oh [ __ ] it man
so which which the main when we first
shot her when we had to go back to
reshoots which one actually neither so I
was on the second units with Dave Ellis
God rest his soul oh my god were you in
the cemetery yeah
a cemetery yeah David Ellis was the
director of amongst many things snakes
on a plane yes even after snakes on a
plane he continued doing what he was
most well-known for in the industry
before he broke out with what was the
movie where my final destination final
destination that was his breakout movie
but David was a wonderful stuntman who
aggregated into a second unit director
and became one of the finest second unit
directors in the business so when we're
making cop out at one point like the
production was like hey we could do two
things at once on this day we could do
the main unit with our actors and [ __ ]
and we can send a second unit director
to do the car stuff in the cemetery and
I was like second unit director I've
never like had that on one of my movies
yeah like [ __ ] what does that mean
well I get like I do I share a credit
and [ __ ] they're like now they're called
second unit directors as I well who is
this cat and they're like David Ellis
man he's one of the best in business I
was like
wait a second this guy did stakes on
playing they like yeah but he's a stunt
guy and then they just told me what I
just told you so I said all right
they're like he wants to talk to you
before it goes down though before it
comes out he's coming in from Hawaii and
[ __ ] I said alright and I got on the
phone with him I was like hey man how
are you and he's like great really
looking forward to this like I've seen
your flex and I love him this stuff as
this one's not really mine so it could
be way different he's going huh I said
I've never had a second you are you guys
is gonna be easy man I'm here to help
and [ __ ] he goes I understand you like
weed I said very much and he goes
alright just wanted to make sure bye and
he hung up David Ellis sent me a bunch
of weed before the movie began like a
care package got to the [ __ ] set and
I opened it up and it was just like see
you soon love David and it was like
little Tiki glasses and inside they were
packed with [ __ ] Weed Man
so when he came to the set I was like
welcome brother he was such an amazing
[ __ ] guy what a like great spirit
amazing week as it came from why it's
flat-out Maui wowie but he told me this
great [ __ ] story is such a sweet dude
his story about being a stunt guy he was
like I was like what is that like he's
like I saved my life one day I said how
he's going we were in New Orleans
shooting and it was during his post
Katrina or something it was really bad
time to be down there and stuff he was
like I wasn't in a neighborhood I should
have been I wound up going into like a
dead-end cold the sack kind of affair
and I got tailed in by another car and
then another car pulled in front of me
he's like I looked out and people
started getting out of their cars
reaching into their pants and stuff and
aggressively heading toward me I said
what you do
he's like Wallace stop man so I just
[ __ ] through it reverse and did this
vicious like 180 spun right around the
nose that's awesome and then came to a
pause but the engine gunning facing the
direction to lead out I was like what
they do and he was like everybody was
[Laughter]
awesome I love that guy he was I'm sure
he was a joy to work with that night he
was amazing man like he would he just
treated everyone with such respect and
dignity and
this is a guy who like hadn't gone on to
like direct movies and [ __ ] so like he
could have been fooling himself but he
was such a good [ __ ] dude man really
good dude do you think the criminals who
like wanted to rob him or like okay well
we didn't get his wallet but that was
[ __ ] rad I'm sure those [ __ ]
told that story for the rest of their
lives so like one time we almost got
this guy but he did a 180 he was like
The Dukes of Hazzard man it's kind of
crazy
anyway what's your question okay so two
quick questions the first one is so I'm
trying to break in it's a director now
and all that and there's kind of a
count's fight with with a lot of people
i socialize with them whatever it's like
we're all trying to get our foot in and
it we're all thinking about ourselves
all the time and I'm wondering for all
three of you because Zack it seems like
you're definitely in the same boat here
what is it that keeps the humility what
is it that keeps you guys so kind of
grounded down to earth wanting to keep
coming back and talk to all of us you
know I'm sure yeah I'm sure there's a
paycheck but I mean you do you don't do
it for that
right you do it because you love it so
like what what is it that nice yeah I
think he means the Paycheck here which I
assure you is not so it's here we do it
for the love you do it because like oh
people want to hear us talk about you
like anybody cares we're there whether
they gather in my name [ __ ] do you
think I'm gonna ignore that like I'm all
about that that's that's how you build
religions and [ __ ] like that so
so I'm but keeping humble is you know
[ __ ] easy it's like especially like
I've never had like breakout crazy
success that I've been spoiled by you
know what I'm saying so I've had I've
been successful by my own standards but
not to the point where it's like holy
[ __ ] [ __ ] like I could do whatever I
want
well actually I can do whatever I want
but not like well no I do do whatever I
want
yeah I don't know I don't know what
keeps me humble like honestly I don't
know I was raised well just like no I
don't have like very much self-esteem
good parents that helped and [ __ ] helped
to be heavy most of my life keeps
perspective straight and [ __ ] you don't
get too full of yourself because even no
matter what I did I help the being
online a lot like I was online since
people started going online in the
mainstream not in colleges and [ __ ] but
like from ninety late 94 early 95 onward
and that'll keep you [ __ ] humble
because no matter what you do look like
those were like some of the best years
of my career Rose doing like killer work
and the internet will just make you feel
like you [ __ ] suck and you're like
you're right and I [ __ ] worked under
that delusion for a long [ __ ] time
that helps keep you humble as well but I
don't know seeing people do way better
than you seeing you know work [ __ ]
continue for years or like be well-known
later on is easy just stay humble to me
it'd be harder to become an [ __ ] I
think till like really lose your head
about it and be like my [ __ ] don't stink
or whatever those [ __ ] people I've
never been a Yeller I know that happens
a lot in our business and [ __ ]
particularly on the directorial front
and I've never quite understood that
like how do you get to some place in
your career where you're being paid to
make pretend for a [ __ ] living you're
gonna yell at somebody else about it
kids don't even [ __ ] do that when
they're making pretend and the ones that
do they don't get to make pretend
anymore like no no you did it wrong it's
like [ __ ] you go home and [ __ ] should be
the same in the movie business man but
some people get away with being [ __ ]
and forgetting how [ __ ] lucky they
are to be paid to make pretend for a
living I've never forgotten that I heard
the this guy is being way too modest I
heard from the flash crew
that and the in the writers and the
actors and things like that they're like
we love bringing Kevin in at about the
2/3 point of the season because
everyone's kind of like over it by then
and everyone's kind of like oh it's
still got to do this job and you know
like not feeling very grateful and then
Kevin comes in and like after every take
he's like best job in the world and
things like that he fires us up and like
like we feel grateful again and things
like that and he's like a huge morale
boost and and they love him I just like
forget myself and what I'm no matter
what I'm working on you your job as the
director is to keep people in foods but
also remind him like you are breathing
[ __ ] rarefied air right now like it's
like less than 5% of the world will ever
get to make pretend beyond their [ __ ]
childhood and have somebody can I'm a
[ __ ] paycheck to do so so enjoy it it
gets no better than this yeah in in 20
it's always been this way but in 2019 in
particular there are so many choices for
entertainment in so many choices for
where your eyeballs in your brain are
going to go of for the 7 billion people
on earth that I have I've written and
co-written books and gone to book
signings where there were two people in
the audience and it's like and you know
what you give the speech to to people
and you're grateful for those two people
but it makes you realize there are so
many options for everyone out there that
if anyone wants to hear what you have to
say and see the stories that you have to
tell your one attitude should be [ __ ]
gratitude yeah lean into that
[Applause]
for for me it's it's it's remembering
how you got there you know like because
this town is filled with people who all
want to be doing this thing right they
want to be writers who want to be
directors it would it be actors and
there are people among them who also
want to do the same thing there's a
fellowship of people who are all
desiring and all aspiring to to some
level of success and never remembering
what it felt like to be that person who
wanted it and worked really hard for it
and never remembering that people that
you encountered along the way helped you
get there because it's impossible to do
it by yourself there needs to be people
who will take a chance on you they need
to be people who'd be like hey man you
seem not like an [ __ ] sure I might
read your script dude that I know from
the internet it doesn't happen often
mind you don't send me your scripts
people I know from the internet but but
the idea that people have taken a chance
on you and you owe it to them to have
not proven that chance wasted you know
and and to when you can help the next
generation of people learn better how to
do what they want to do if they have a
dedication to the craft if they have a
dedication to get better at it to help
them you know it's and and to still
remember that even while you're humble
you worked really hard to get there like
there's kind of nothing wrong with the
be humble but let [ __ ] know
motto like that's my family crest like
be humble but let [ __ ] know
you've worked really hard to get there
you worked really hard to get good at
this you work really hard to get people
to pay you to do make-believe for money
but remember that when you got there you
didn't get there alone remember that
when you got there there were people who
took time out of their lives to help you
get there and you owe something to the
people after you who still want to get
there too great question you win get
your tickets get your poster man you are
fired
oh yeah cuz I had to but know you had
one
come get your poster and your [ __ ]
ticket you want man
well done brother where we going next JC
I would be remiss if I didn't also say
that Zacks tens was one of those people
who took the time out of his lives to
help me get better at this
he read like now he'd get tickets and he
read early pilots of mine he was a first
reader he said hey I think you might
have something you just need to take
time and the world will cycle itself
around to be ready for you when you're
ready for it and I would not have made
it as far as I did it for there we're
not people like Zack and specifically
Zack who took time out to make sure I
didn't give up so hi Kevin hi what's
your name Kiva keep it was that right
coming up for Kiva if you each got your
own chance to take any Marvel or DC
character put it on Netflix with your
own creative everything was your own
idea own specifics the way you wanted it
what would be your character hmm I've
does DC or marvel my DC is always the
question I think that would make such a
great series with me there must be a
reason why they're not doing it I know
they've got some weird ownership issues
with the character because he came
through the Charlton deal they bought
those characters years ago and don't
know if that included movie rights or
something like that where TV rights but
I love I love that I think the question
would be [ __ ] great right a year ago
I would have said that it's like well
I'd love to do the Grant Morrison run on
the Doom Patrol but no one would ever do
that on TV [ __ ] now they're doing it
how crazy is that I'm like a huge Grant
Morrison like deconstruction and things
things like that guy I would love to do
an animal man I would love to do do a
run on you know or a TV version of Buddy
Baker with like all of the crazy stuff
and all of the fourth wall breaking and
like taking peyote and like seeing the
reader and stuff and then
going to visit you know like in this I'd
say Grant Morrison but you know let's
not [ __ ] ourselves it would be like
going to visit Greg Berlanti at the end
would you do it cartoon or live-action
oh I do it live-action you can find a
like good-looking blonde guy somewhere
or he doesn't have to be blonde he could
be anything that had a great issue in
the animal man run like it was a great
book and it was better than I had any
right to be but Graham Morrison's a
genius but he then he put the character
through [ __ ] hell and then took his
family away and [ __ ] and then eventually
took the character to the edge of the
comic and then Buddy Baker spoilers if
you've never read it but give it a read
it's one of the greatest comic books
ever written Buddy Baker meets his
Creator which is Grant Morrison so
there's a whole issue where Buddy Baker
the character of Animal Man is talking
to Grant Morrison he's like why why why
have you done this to me and he's like
don't you understand he's like you just
entertainment he's like I don't even
write you all the time do you ever
notice when you were the Justice League
you sound completely different he's like
yeah I did notice that but it's a really
wonderful issue about creativity and
stuff and him meeting his maker was just
so groundbreaking in genius man one of
my favorite comic books ever written
great Paul let's do it together
[ __ ] yeah you make it I'll watch it I'll
[ __ ] it up I'll promote it for you guys
totally Greg if you're listening we'll
do it do you know how Greg stay so
[ __ ] successful and rich you don't
watch it like this over to you if I
gotta pick a Marvel blade yeah [ __ ] I'd
watch a series about blam I'd really
watch as they brought back [ __ ]
Snipes yes I think I think Snipes gets
to be Whistler in this version and then
you use [ __ ] geek read that [ __ ] at
this point that's true but to be fair I
saw him in person
yeah I saw him in person in the flesh
Wesley Snipes at the Stan Lee event at
the Chinese month back he looks the
exact same
oh he could totally still play blade he
could but you're not gonna do that
say a blade blade for Marvel and I think
I would do trends metropolitan ah look I
think right about now is the perfect
time for a journalist to take down a
wholly corrupt president and also why
would you want to do that you mean in
the comic books I know but it also to
get to talk about sort of body
dysmorphia and and and gene-splicing and
everything that that book was pre
shipped about is now just about bleeding
edge of where we are today and identity
and politics and identity politics and
why those can never really be divorced
from one another I think that time is
perfect for that to happen I want to see
that so do i and then I just have a
quick thing can you say my box yeah what
the [ __ ] happy - happy - she's never
heard it quite put that way do you want
but she won tickets back give it up you
want poster tickets come get your [ __ ]
well done
alright JC where we going next
ah the last soldier good evening guys
hey man what's your name my name's James
James everyone give it up for James so
my question to you guys is Marvel
introduced us to the Avengers with Tony
Stark and Iron Man and they teased fan
oohs as the overall villain through 22
movies it was now that they own the
mutants if you guys were approached by
Marvel and had to pick an opening mutant
to to lead that next arc and they wanted
to to mirror that who would you pick as
the mutant and who would your big bad be
throughout the arc okay okay my entry
mutant the Iron Man - my x-men storm
yeah like I just think that we have
never seen the good version of storm and
I think there's nothing but upside now
to be able to talk about refugees and
famine and what it feels like to have
the responsibility to be able to fix
that but not be everywhere at all times
and and I think yeah no [ __ ] storm
the bad guy for storm I still yeah I
mean I'm still pulling for Submariner I
don't think he's the appropriate but its
water so yeah [ __ ] I'm gonna stick
there I feel like I did well in the
first yeah you had them in the first one
well you had a few people and then at
the end you completely lose embarrass
[ __ ] show them the magic show them
how you make that money show them how
you make that Netflix money I think you
want to start with Kitty Pryde oh you
took my [ __ ] answer you genius I
looked at his homework I'm sorry why do
you think so and I'll tell you why I
think so no because you're the cartoon
that's why I think so I'm like they did
it in the cartoon and it worked so well
you know let like we've seen the Marvel
you know we've seen the Marvel hero is
like douchey middle-aged white guy
learning how to be a better to be a
better person we haven't really you know
and we had Captain
you know we had Captain Marvel which was
a great movie but it you know she was
already kind of fully formed in her own
way I you know like the x-men you know
they're teenagers
that's that's what it was you know like
is much of a metaphor for other kinds of
outside Erdem as as the x-men have come
to be over the course of you know this
Jewishness blackness being gay what when
it started like being a teenager
especially in the 1960s felt like being
an outsider and it feels like going back
to that going back to that is a great
place to start to kind of build out that
mutant universe from and then
you know villains I like a lot of the
x-men villains but you know like I go
with the Hellfire Club or like mr.
sinister or someone like that I don't
care though okay you go I'm gonna revise
my villain answer I have a better
villain answer but you go first
alright I'm co-signing on Kitty Pryde I
think you don't she's not founding
member of the x-men I don't think you'd
do it like they did the Avengers were
it's just like slowly there are enough
heroes to make a team and stuff I think
you play the Avengers who we've now seen
for nearly 20 years and a bunch of other
movies like the shark in Jaws like
you're not gonna see them until the
[ __ ] third act they got to be the
shining city on the hill that Kitty
Pryde is working toward do you include
Lackey the dragon or no [ __ ] yeah you
want to dragons are big now I will say
as someone who co-wrote an x-men movie
my favorite depiction of the x-men on
screen is whenever they show up in
Deadpool is like those colossus and
negasonic teenage warhead scenes in
Deadpool feel like the x-men from the
comic books it's like it's like we're
sitting eating cereal and Xavier's
mansion and oh [ __ ] look on the TV we
gotta go like someone's doing something
idiotic that we've got to go to and
you're my trainee like it's like it was
this demonstration that like oh yeah the
original concept of the x-men [ __ ]
works do that for my villain I go arcade
because it'll be fun and it'll appeal to
the kids and you know we live in a world
of video games and play that up pretty
pretty tight I'd imagine that's mine
what's your villain my new villain this
is take two on my bad guy Charles Xavier
Professor X is the bad
the bad guy because I think from her
perspective what the [ __ ] does this
colonizer doing here why does he keep
wanted to invite me to his [ __ ]
school like that idea of the other
coming to take me someplace for that
character that orphan could be
frightening and awful if that characters
speaking to your mind Charles Xavier is
a [ __ ] nightmare creation if you look
at it from another perspective as genius
man I want to see your movie market as
do I Disney / Fox / Marvel well I would
also like to see this movie he's a
[ __ ] great save cuz the first we were
all like no more [ __ ] you know what a
great answer what a great question give
it up for me Juan pleasure it's always
depressing when we end the show hearing
about a movie we're never gonna see man
but that's what we do here at fat man
beyond ladies and gentlemen have you had
a good time this evening I cannot thank
you enough for coming out being with
this here tonight remember we're doing
this again next week next Tuesday next
Tuesday same fad time right here at at
the scum and villainy Cantina but man oh
man we had a great time tonight because
the guy is standing here between us give
it up for the font of information the
rim of the world man give it up Razak
stands ladies and gentlemen I learned
how to self promote from Kevin he's
wearing that goddamn shirt but there is
no fat man beyond unless the guy to the
left of the guy to my left
stands up and pontificates it tells us
what he knows give it up for the great
mark Bernard and ladies German thank you
thank you and that is Batman Beyond for
this week I'm Kevin Smith I am aqua tune
in next week same bat-time same
bat-channel SModcast calm or youtube.com
/ Kevin Smith for the good of all
Creegan island
[Applause]
[Music]
you